hi i'm joshua
and i'll be talking about algorithms and
hardness for multi-dimensional range
updates and queries
this is the longer form of a talk to be
given at itcs 2021
and this is a joint work with english
for torso
so just jumping in i'll first start by
talking about traditional orthogonal
range problems
so in traditional orthogonal range
problems one's given maybe in 2d a set
of p
points each with some value and each of
these points is located in the plane
the task is to construct a data
structure that facilitates
online queries over ranges of these
points
and the answer to each query is some
information or some aggregate
about the points that lie in that range
so
for instance in this example if we query
this range
we might ask for the number of points in
that range which is two
we might ask for the maximum value in
the range which is five
and we also consider dynamic versions of
this data structures problem
where points can be added or removed so
for instance if we add a point
say the six here we can then perform
queries over this modified data set
so the maximum this range is eight and
the sum in this range is 18.
so each individual problem is
parameterized
by the type of queries that are
supported
so if where p is the number of points
in two dimensions if our query is either
asking for the sum which we denote by a
plus
because this is the semi-group operator
or
or max which asks for the maximum value
in the range
we can solve these in order log squared
p time
or better for operation depending on
which queries and what sort of updates
are supported
and for an opera by an operation we
mean either adding a point or removing a
point or
issuing a query but
say we want to use more powerful updates
over our data set where we want to
modify more than a point
what can we do so to this end in our
work we introduce
the idea of range updates so consider
this set of points here
in a range update we might be able to
we will provide a range and a constant
say 2
and we'll allow updates which replace
the value
of each uh point in that range
with two that gives us this data set
and we also investigate and are
interested in different types of updates
so for instance maybe updates that plus
or add or increment
a constant to all points that fall
within a range
like so uh and another update which
we call max or a maximizer
replaces the value of each point within
a particular range
with the update specific constant
so in this case this is uh maximizing
width 2
and as you can see this zero over here
has changed to a two over here
because the maximum of zero and two is
two
but this three remains unchanged because
of four of course three is greater than
two
so we also have a min an equivalent min
update uh which does the same except
replaces the value with the minimum
of say two and the value of the point
so the types of problems we get here can
be described by
the query that's supported so either
plus or max
are under our consideration and a set of
updates not just one the set
uh and in our work we consider plus
updates main updates set updates
and max updates and subsets of these
so in one dimension uh it's already
known that it amortized
or log squared p time per query we can
support each operation uh and we can do
better depending on the set of updates
and
the choice of query that's supported but
not much is known in two dimensions
so our work mainly explores two
dimensions
in two dimensions we show that
with a sort of a simple algorithm um
with using a kd3
we can flatten our problem in two
dimensions or actually in arbitrarily
many dimensions
uh to a 1d problem and thus we obtain
uh order or roughly order
square root of p time updates we use
this tilde o
notation to suppress poly logarithmic
factors so this is the square root of p
times some poly logarithm of p
uh and i'll just for sure i'll be i'll
just be calling this roughly
square root of p and we find
matching or nearly matching lower bounds
that are predicated on the online matrix
vector conjecture which we'll
discuss shortly and
we base our lower bounds say that
there's no solution
that runs in p to the 0.5 minus epsilon
for any epsilon greater than zero
unless the online matrix vector
sorry there's unless the online matrix
vector conjecture
is false so the models
the models that we've considered so far
revolve around points
there's a point set and we and there's a
fixed set of p
points and we do some updates to those
points
and those are useful for maybe
representing
a database table so you might have
a person with an age a height and you
and based on the numerical values you
might perform updates
but another model we consider is
is that of arrays so
let's say we have this 2d array here
which is initially all zero
we can perform similar sort of updates
to these so we sort of consider each
array cell as a point
so okay as an example with
using just set updates we can set this
row to 6 we can set this range of
columns to two
and then we can query over a specific
range
and so if this was a sum query and we
would return 24 here
which is the sum of the values and if
this is a max query we would return 6
because this is the maximum value
in this range and we can continue
supporting updates after that
and queries after that and so this is
the sort of problem
that we're looking at when it comes to
arrays
so we also consider other different
types of updates similarly to our point
model
so we can we consider adding a value so
in this case we can even add a negative
value
and maximizing with five
or any other constant and minimizing
just the same as before
again we consider the same set of
operations
for our queries and
in our model we're mainly focused on
measuring complexity or time complexity
as a function of n where n is the number
of updates and
queries so
in a model we assume we have an
arbitrarily large 2d array that's all
initially zero
and we allow n of these operations which
is sort of the size of the input
and we measure complexity in terms of n
so in terms of prior work that's been
done we know
on arrays in 1d we have the exact same
results as
for points and it's pretty um
they're pretty similar actually in terms
of their structure and they
run again in poly logarithmic time per
operation
now from this it's not too difficult to
see that
in roughly order in time for operation
we can solve this for 2d and
to do this we can consider the
uh the n different updates or updating
query
um operations and their ranges and that
sort of divides the grid
uh divides the array into an n by n grid
and for each row or for each row in that
grid
we can keep a 1d instance so just by
keeping n 1d
instances we can solve the 2d instance
in
order and order and roughly order n time
for operation
or order n squared time or roughly order
and square time overall
in two dimensions we can solve
on arrays the problem of
plus updates and plus and sum queries
uh and we can do this in order log
squared and time per operation and
that's
um an existing result in the literature
and it's
uh we're using a similar technique we
can we can handle
max updates and max queries as well
so those instances we can do fairly
efficiently
in the special case we're in 2d where
the update range covers a single point
this is much like our previous point
model where we
add or remove a single point um in a
single update
and similarly this can be done in a
similar time
and finally the
more similar models to the ones that
we're looking at revolve around
two problems that have been studied uh
quite extensively
so one is clease measure which asks to
maintain
n rectangles uh in 2d and
as these rectangles are added or removed
one needs to report the area of the
union of the rectangles
and for weighted depth it's a similar
problem where each rectangle is assigned
a certain weight
and after each additional removal of a
rectangle
we need to report the point in the plane
that's covered by the rectangles whose
sum
of weights is maximum and
we can facilitate this well it's known
that this can be solved in roughly
uh order root n time property where n is
the total number of operations
so the main question we'll be trying to
solve is how hard is this problem
on on two-dimensional arrays for
different sorts of updates and different
sorts of queries
and the one thing i'd like you to take
away from this talk
is just to have an idea of how these uh
how these problems
work have a feel of how the updates and
the queries work together
how hard they are and also just to take
a little bit of
take away a little bit of insight into
how
their complexity relates to the
complexity of other problems that have
been studied
so we start with this picture of the
complexity of our different problems
so down below we have in nearly linear
time over n operations
uh these two problems that we've
discussed before so recall that each of
their
each of these can be solved um in order
log squared end time
for operation so over n operations this
is nearly linear time
and up the top here we can support all
of these updates
with either a max query or a sum query
in roughly order and squared time using
those
order n one dimensional instances
so the question is is there anything in
between
so first up we'll some problems where
we have a single update operation and a
single query operation
and the question is well can these be
solved in roughly linear time too
and to answer this question we'll
establish some lower bounds
that show that this is probably not the
case
so we'll our lower bounds will be
conditional
condition on various popular conjectures
and the first one we'll be considering
is the online matrix vector conjecture
so to do that we'll introduce the ou and
the oumv problem which is as follows
so you're given an m by m boolean matrix
it's called m and you have to answer m
online queries um each
giving you a subset of rows say r
and a subset of columns says t and one
needs to determine if there exists a
pair
um or a cell in the in section of the
rows and the columns
such that the cell is one
so for instance if the subset of rows
given is the top
and the bottom row and the middle column
the two cells in the intersection are
these green ones here
and they're both one so each section
contains a one and the answer is yes
in the second example we're given the
same set of
columns but the set of sorry the same
set of rows but the set of columns is
the first and the last
the intersection is these greens the
green ones again and there's no ones the
answer is no
and in this last example the
intersection is just that one cell that
contains a one and the answer is yes
once again
so while this isn't exactly the on the
omv or online matrix vector conjecture
it was shown in the paper that
originally proposed this conjecture
that this problem is sub-cubic
equivalent to the online matrix vector
problem
so what that means is there is no truly
sub-cubic
algorithm for this problem that is
facilitating
m online queries on an m-by-m grid
in time order m to the three minus
epsilon for some positive epsilon
overall unless this omb conjecture is
false
so there are three conditions in a given
query
for the answer to be yes so there must
be a cell
that sorry there's a cell that satisfies
the three conditions the three
conditions being
the sellers in one of the rows of r
the cell is in one of the columns of c
and the cell
also contains a one in the matrix m so
we'll use this fact to reduce to
the problem where we support plus
updates so
incrementing a range of values
and max queries as in returning the
maximum value in a range
so we'll use order m squared updates to
initialize the grid
so the grid is initially zero using
order m squared updates
will set the value of each cell so that
it resembles our matrix m
now for a given query we'll check for
the three conditions by first
for each of the rows we'll increment
them by one
and for each of the columns we'll
increment them by one
and it's easy to see that the cells that
have value
three are the ones that satisfy all
three conditions
and these are the only ones that compare
value through
and so to test if any such cell exists
we can use a maximum query
to check for three and finally to get
ready for the next query
because the queries are being done
online we can undo the updates and so we
do them by
adding negative one to each of those
rows
or columns so
we can and once we do that we repeat for
the remaining queries
this reduction uses order m squared
operations overall
and so because there's no
truly sub-cubic algorithm for
oumv under the under the online matrix
vector conjecture
uh that means that under the same
conjecture there should be no
order into the one and a half minus
epsilon time solution
for this plus update and max query so
using a similar reduction
we can show similar hardness for pretty
much
all of our other single update uh
single update instances except for those
which we saw earlier that have roughly
linear time solutions already
so if we go back to our picture under
the online matrix vector conjecture
there's none of these can be solved in
roughly linear time
in fact they require into the 1.5 time
and under the orphes shortest path
conjecture we show similar hardness for
that problem that we just looked at
before
okay so if there's no roughly linear
time solution for these problems
maybe they're really hard
so let's look at the hardness for a
problem that's
a little bit harder than these one that
nearly embodies all of the operations
for one of our harder like the hardest
problems
so in this case we'll consider the
the consider problem which supports plus
updates
max updates and plus queries and we ask
well
can they be solved any faster than
roughly n squared time
and the answer one again once again will
be no and we'll show that under the
three sum conjecture
so the three sum problem gives as input
m integers
and the task is to check whether there
are three values a b and c
among these integers such that a plus b
equals c
the three sum conjecture states that
this can't be done in truly subquadratic
time
so to solve this uh we'll first we'll
let's consider an example with an array
a which
is just one two three four and five as
input
uh and we'll use our plus update to
construct an addition table
so first we'll add one two three four
and five
to each of our each of our columns and
then we'll do the same for our rows
now each of these values will contain uh
the value of a prospective
a plus b so these can be
thought of as the a's these can be
thought of as the b's
and we'll iterate through our array
choosing each one one by one
and saying well maybe this is c and
seeing if there is an a plus b
in the grid that matches um that matches
lc
so let's say lc is four to check if
there's a four
in the grid we'll count the number we
want to count the number of cells that
are equal to four
and this can be written as the numbers
that are at most four
minus the number that are at most three
recall that we're dealing with integers
so to so now we'll try and count the
number that are in
for so to do that
we'll first apply a max update with four
over the entire grid
now the ones that have changed in value
are the ones that were at most four
and they've all changed to four which is
this green section here
and then we'll apply a max update
using 5 as our maximizer and the ones
that have changed value
here are the ones that are that were 4
before
because everything was at least four
after the max operation and they've all
incremented by one to five all of those
cells that were
greater than or equal to five or
strictly greater than four haven't
changed at all
so we can observe that the number of
cells that are less or equal to some x
is the sum of uh the number
so sorry the number of cells that are
at most four is equal to the sum of this
a5 grid
minus the sum of this a4 grid and more
generally we can write it as
this for for a general x
so using just two updates and a single
query
we're able to count the number less than
or equal to a certain amount
and that's enough to determine for each
element in the array whether or not
there's an a plus b
that matches it this uses order
m operations overall and so under the
threesome conjecture
there's no truly subquadratic time for
this problem
so how does this affect our complexity
graph
well we know that for this problem
there's probably no
sub quadratic time algorithm under the
threesome conjecture
and for this other problem here which
involves plus updates min updates and
max queries
which is a subset of the updates in this
hard problem
we uh under the
under the orthogonal vectors conjecture
we show similar hardness as well
so because we know that all of these are
solvable in roughly quadratic time
and we have a nearly
quadratic time lower bound or
conditional lower bound
we see that these form almost type
solutions for these problems
okay so we have some hard problems up
here
and we know that these problems with
single updates
all have all require at least into the
one
into the 1.5 time roughly so the
question is
maybe these are really hard and maybe
these
also require uh at least quadratic time
so is this the case well to answer this
um we now turn our attention to upward
bounds so we we seek to find algorithms
actually solve these problems
and where our goal is to find algorithms
that solve these in
truly sub-quadratic time
so our main approach uses this idea of
trellises
so over mars and yap in 1991 when they
were tackling
the cleese measure problem they prove
the following result
and so they prove that if you have n
rectangles in the plane
we can partition the plane into order n
parts which they call trellises
such that no rectangle's vertex is in in
any part
and each part is only partially covered
by order squared and rectangles
so a part might be wholly covered by
many many rectangles but it could only
have partial overlap with it
most square root of order square root of
n rectangles
so our idea is that we'll treat our
update ranges as these rectangles
so in each of these three cases
um this black square here represents a
part
so if each of these black squares is a
part and each of these
rectangles in update range there's only
three ways that an
update range can overlap with this part
so one is
um that it overlaps horizontally as in
it covers the entire width of
the part but
it entire causes the entire width of the
part and maybe some subset of its height
it could be the same thing but
vertically
or it could wholly cover the part
and these are the only cases because any
other partial overlap
would mean that a vertex of this
rectangle
lies inside the part which is not
allowed by the first condition
so the theorem basic
means that there are only square root of
and horizontal or vertical parts because
they partially cover this rectangle
but they could be ordering updates that
wholly cover a part
and we can get around these by using
some
range update tricks especially for the
problems that we've considered
but we don't talk about the we won't
talk about these in detail these are
covered in more detail in the paper
so what we'll do is we'll
treating the each updated range as such
a rectangle we
provide in the paper a reduction to a
simple version of these
of our original problems so in our
simple version of problems
we can treat this black square as a as
the entire grip on the
entire array and these blue and red
strips
uh are treat our update ranges so
we basically reduced our original
problem where rangers could
have arbitrary geometry and could lie
arbitrarily in the plane
we reduce that instance to one where we
only care about
we all we only have to think about
objects which either wholly cover the
width
or wholly cover the the height of our
array
so another way of saying it is that each
of our updates
either covers all columns and
some rows or all rows and some columns
and over mazenya i guess they called it
a trellis because
they look kind of like these garden
trellises over here
so how do we solve this special case
well going back to our
plus update max query problem uh we can
see this example
so let's say we add one to this row
we add two to these columns we add four
to these rows and we add eight to these
columns
producing the following grid now if we
want to find the maximum of some range
first we'll write on the top of each
or compute for each column the total
amount that's been added to these
columns
just by these vertical updates or these
column updates so you can notice that
for this particular column
it's had plus 10 overall added to it
because there's been a plus eight
update applied to these two columns and
a plus two update applied to these three
columns
which both affect this one column and we
do the same for rows
now if we take a range like the
following to find
maximum the maximum value contained in
the range it suffices to find the
maximum value
among the rows that the range lies in
which in this case is 4
and the maximum value of the columns it
lies in which in this case is 10.
and we can add them together now the
reason we can do this
is because the update distributes over
the query so we can sort of have
we can solve each dimension
independently and combine the results
later
this is a sufficient condition but not a
necessary condition
so we can do we can solve in a similar
way some other problems that don't
necessarily satisfy this distributive
property
the improvement we make over existing
methods
uh known for weighted depth and for
clean measure is that we make this fully
dynamic
so in previous approaches the
decomposition
into these different parts required that
the coordinates of
all of the rectangles be known
beforehand so before any updates or
queries
um or were handled but
in our case we're able to make this
fully dynamic um
meaning that even if the updated query
ranges aren't known when we start and
when we do pre-computation
that's okay so that means we can solve
variants that satisfy this property and
roughly into the one and a half time
so that that approach works for our plus
update max query problem as well as our
min update max period problem
the set update max query problem doesn't
quite satisfy the distributive property
but we're still able to solve the
problem in the same sort
of way
okay so this gives us roughly tighten
the hardness for this end to the
1.5 class of problems
but it still remains how we solve this
set update plus query problem
so we'll now look at solving that so
as an example we can set this row to b6
this these columns to be eight this row
to be seven
these verbs to be seven and this column
these columns to be nine
now the trouble is we can't use the same
technique from before
because the dimensions aren't
independent so for instance this cell
here
its value is sort of nine if we just
considered the vertical updates
but its value would be seven if we just
consider the horizontal updates
and there's no straightforward way to
combine these two together
in a batch way without considering
dimensions together
so to solve this sort of problem we
introduce a new tool
that we prove in our paper and we prove
the following theorem so for this
problem where plus query and set updates
we show that if we can solve a static
trellis instance
so static means that all the updates
come before all the queries
if we can solve such a special instance
in this complexity
we'll get a truly subquadratic time
solution
so this complexity is a little bit
complex but if n equals q
this just becomes n to the 1.5 minus
epsilon
and this gamma which varies which can be
anything between zero and one
um is this so that we can obtain uh some
additive
uh sub-additive running time with
respect to q so if there are many
queries
um it it doesn't take too long
so this can so this theorem is more
general than this
and actually applies when we can solve
from partial information
so we won't go through what exactly that
means that's covered in the paper
but set update and plug queries satisfy
this requirement and this is a necessary
condition for this theorem to work
okay so with armed with this how do we
solve
our setup date plus query problem well
first we make some simplifications uh
the value of each cell is derived either
from a
horizontal query a horizontal update or
a vertical update
so without loss of generality if we're
looking for the sum of a range we can
consider these two
cases separately so to do that we'll
assume that the vertical update is
always set to zero
and we're just considering the value
derived from horizontal updates
similarly we can consider the horizontal
updates
as binary strings so they're values like
seven and six we can write them as
binary strings and consider each power
of two in turn
if the power of two is zero then it
doesn't really change the value of
the horizontal update so we can assume
that
all the horizontal all the horizontal
updates
are set to one so if there's a zero
update and there's later a one update
the one will win out
but for simplicity
and without loss of generality we can
assume that all the horizontal updates
set to one and now
from the simplified version we can
reduce to
uh range inversion counting on a race
so this is a problem on arrays um and to
reduce
we'll first determine for each row
and for each column the time of the
latest
horizontal or vertical update that
fully covers that column or row so for
instance
this column over here was covered
originally by
update at time two and then later an
update at time four
so the latest update covering it is time
four
and we have the same deal for rows from
these times we can construct an array
which is just the concatenation of these
times for our rows
and these times for our columns so this
is one array
now if we look at the time con if we
look at the
the value of a particular cell we can
see that it's one
if the row update was after the column
update
and it's zero otherwise so in this case
this cell is one because
its row update is three and its column
update is two and the row is greater
but this cell is its value is zero
because its column update was at time
one
uh its row up there was a time one and
column update was a time four
so naturally if we look at a range of
rows and a range of columns
the sum of values in that range is equal
to the number of inversions between
the this range of rows and this range of
columns
where an inversion is a pair with the
first element drawn from
the the first range the second element
drawn from the second range
and the first element being greater than
the second element
so how is this helpful well if you
recall from our theorem we require
something that
runs in strictly faster than ends the
1.5 time
to train a truly subquadratic time
solution overall
so we have the following equivalences in
between various problems so we've just
shown
that when we have n updates and
inquiries in
a static trailer's version of this
problem this we can reduce to
a similarly sized instance of inversion
counting
on an array of size n also with n
queries
and in in the paper we show a reduction
the other way
while we're showing an equivalence
between these two problems
in a recent work there was an
equivalence shown between
that inversion counting problem and edge
triangle counting on a graph with n
edges
uh which asks given a graph for every
edge
count the number of triangles that is
three cycles
that contain that edge and the same work
showed that all of these are solvable in
into the 1.407 time which is handy
because this is less or strictly less
than the 1.5 that we need
but recall from the statement of the
theorem
that we actually require some
multivariate version of this
so if instead we have q queries
where which is not the same as the
number of updates
um we have a similar equivalence to
inversion counting with q queries
but in this case um the instance of
inversion counting is equivalent not to
edge triangle counting
but to two path counting which asks
given an edge
an n edge graph and cube of taxpayers
how many two paths or paths of length
two
are there between each for a text pair
and this is solvable in this time
complexity
where these two exponents add up to that
1.407 number that we saw before
and so this gives us a truly
sub-quadratic time algorithm
for um our set up date plus query
problem in general not just when the
query just updates a static trellis
and it gives this term complexity
now when we also allow plus updates
thrown into the mix we instead give a
reduction to a generalization of
inversion counting
which we don't talk about here but it's
talked about in the paper
and we show that this is equivalent to
three path counting so instead of two
parses
three parts uh and we show that
in slightly slower amount of time but
still less than
that sort of ends the 1.5 time overall
we can solve this problem and this gives
for the general problem a truly
sub-quadratic time algorithm that
gets in just under n squared time
so how does this affect our complexity
map well
both the setup date plus query problem
and the
plus update set update and plus query
problem are both solvable and truly
sub-quadratic time
which is good news which means that they
don't fall into this complexity class up
here
using similar techniques we can solve
this problem which allows min updates
setup dates max updates
and max queries uh and it runs in
n to the 1.75 or roughly 0.75 time
over here so all of these like
we know lie at least south of this line
but we don't know
if they can be solved in roughly into
the 1.5 time
down here so we leave these open
and other problems we leave open are
these two so
max updates and plus queries so
we know all we know is that this is at
least as hard as set updates and plus
queries the problem we just spent some
time looking at
just then um through reduction but we
don't know much more than that
so we don't know if they they really lie
this problem really lies up here
um or somewhere in the middle or down
here which would also imply that this
problem lies down there as well
and for this other problem we similarly
don't know which category it belongs in
so it's kind of an open question whether
either of these problems
lies in which of these categories
and so um that concludes our tour
we hope you enjoyed it and hopefully we
can use
these prop these range update problems
to solve other problems as well because
we think that especially in
areas such as dynamic programming
optimization in other areas
reductions to these problems will be
quite natural and so
hopefully establishing complexity of
these problems will give us greater
insight into other problems
thanks for watching